what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so under normal circumstances I
would not refer to this as a Dark
Knight's metal tie-in but it is and the
reason why I say that is for those of
you guys who are new to comic books who
are just getting in the Marvel who are
just getting into DC you usually have
major crossover events and then you have
tie-ins for those events now what DC is
doing with Dark Knights metal is
actually somewhat new when it comes to
DC for the most part whenever DC does
like events they're usually character
driven events the Batman family the
Superman family but you don't usually
see crossover events that are lined wide
which is to say Batman Superman Wonder
Woman the Justice League Green Lantern
the flash they all cross over into this
huge story they do it occasionally but
not very often Marvel does that all the
time which is one of the reasons why
people are kind of getting burned out on
an event fatigue because there's just so
many huge events where so many things
are happening
what DC's doing with Dark Knight's medal
is they're basically telling this
cohesive story and then they're offering
one-shot tie-ins but what this does is
it actually offers some explanation of
what's going on with the Bruce Wayne
character in terms of in metal and his
pursuit of what in metal is and we'll
talk about that once we cross the bridge
of the part of the story that really
brings in the element of a tie-in but
the other half of what this story does
is it offers all kinds of insight into
the character of Ezreal to john-paul
valley now the cool thing about this is
that I guess this really john-paul
valley but with his character he's
really kind of a kind of a relic of the
free new 52 era which is to say he first
popped up in the 1990s now the idea was
that he served his purpose and as we get
through this we'll talk about that he
was really one of these characters where
once his role was played DC was trying
to find a way to keep him relevant to
keep him interesting the problem was
that they really couldn't he had formed
a niche fanbase but outside of that
small fanbase no one really cared what
happened with his character now he's had
appearances in different forms of medium
in the arkham games where he's really
one of the coolest characters but
outside of like hardcore fans people who
really are who read batman or read
comics consistently most people have
long since forgotten who Azrael is now
what this does is it just kind of picks
up at a basketball game and were
immediately met with the arrival of a
character named Nomos and one thing I
want you to notice here is that this
scenario does not immediately include
Batman instead it actually picks up with
that woman
with Lucas Fox and with Ezreal now
that's the nature of Detective Comics
I've seen a few questions about this in
the comment section of my videos which
is one of the reasons why I want to hit
on this when it comes to Superman in
Batman you basically have two different
titles running for each character for
Batman you have the Batman's solo series
and then you have Detective Comics for
Superman you have the Superman solo
series and then action comics the
Superman solo series is designed for the
most part to focus almost exclusively on
Superman it'll feature some supporting
characters but for the most part it just
focuses on him with regards to the
action college line that's when you get
a lot of the supporting characters a lot
of the other characters out there
outside of Lois Lane and Superman's son
Jonathan Kent with Batman it's much the
same way the Batman comics focus almost
exclusively on on Bruce Wayne and then
on the other side you have Detective
Comics the idea is that with DC Reeve
earth what they're doing is actually
telling two separate stories Detective
Comics tells one story Batman tells
another Action Comics tells one story
Superman tells another so I just want to
go ahead and offer that explanation out
there for people who were a little bit
curious about you know how the stories
relate to one another but this story
focuses basically on the bad family
that's really all Detective Comics does
it just tells a wholly separate story
from what the the Batman's solo series
focuses on only end up doing here is
with the arrival of Nomos this basically
begins the process of hitting all the
way back to the you know Batman sword of
Azrael origin story back in 1992 well
not really an origin story so much is
like his first appearance in DC his
origin was actually actually came out of
Azrael annual number one in 1994-95 I
think it was it was after Batman
nightfall but initially we just kind of
pick up with Bruce Wayne now Bruce
Wayne's on the hunt for a person in
particular we don't know who this person
is but with Nomos having effectively
collapsed you know in the presence of
Azrael and that woman in Lucas Fox he's
basically whisked away to the belfry
which is currently the location of where
the bat family hangs out at where they
train practice different things like
that but what this begins to do is it
begins to answer the question regarding
the origin of Azrael
now the idea here is that DC's drawing
on two things they're drawing on
Batman's sword of Azrael and they're
drawing on Azrael annual number one
now the reason why this is important is
because jean-paul Valley got somewhat of
a reboot with the new 52 and while it
wasn't the most well received because DC
rebirth serves the purpose of basically
grabbing old stories and old characters
and old old plot lines and origins that
fans find familiar and rolling it into
the new generation it makes perfect
sense to go all the way back to the
origin story of John Paul Valley how he
existed back in the 1990's and make that
part of the equation and so this falls
directly in line with Batman sort of
Azrael and Azrael annual number one what
we know is that he is basically an
engineered guy he was trained by a group
called the order of st. Dumas now my
knowledge on the original Azrael or at
least the original origin of Azrael is a
little hazy just because of the fact
that it's been so long but the long and
short of it is that with his origin
story the mantle of Azrael is actually a
title that's given to people and the
reason why is because Azrael is one of
the angels
but the idea here was that with the role
of the order of st. Dumas they were a
splinter group from the Knights Templar
the religious sect that existed for
years and years and years and years the
idea was that the order of st. Dumas
breaking off and forming their own
splinter cell
they basically rolled in all these
judeo-christian themes and the idea was
that they functioned for the purpose of
gathering wealth of you know dominating
the world of all these different schemes
that you would expect from traditional
villains now as time progressed they
were basically evolved a little bit more
but the idea is that all their
Assassin's function are really their
their main assassin functions as the
means by which they look to achieve
almost all their goals if there's a
politician that stands in their way
they send their assassin Azrael to take
them out now the way this happens is
that with jean-paul Valley he was
engineered and then he was just kind of
sent out there and the goal was that his
father basically freed him and his
father you know tried to help him live a
normal life eventually his dad was
killed
jean-paul Valley was brought back in and
then he was basically raised and then
allowed to go back out into the world
again and the reason for that is because
of the fact that with the order of st.
Dumas breaking off from the Knights
Templar the order themselves had a rift
within their own group there were those
individuals who said we follow these
religious teachings there were others
who said you're not going far enough and
the ones who said you're not going far
enough are effectively the ones who won
out they basically went through and
started killing all these members of the
of the order of st. Dumas that were
basically not acting extreme enough and
so
result is that with the character of
jean-paul Valley uh he was released out
into the world for the purpose of
gaining his own life of you know forming
a life for himself
probably even starting a family and then
he would be brought back in and then he
would be forced to be conditioned they
would basically break him down on the
most basic psychological level in every
conceivable way and once he was broken
he was simply ceased being a man he
would just be a vessel for what was
called the programming or at least you
know the program or you know the system
or whatever you want to call it
basically this programming that existed
within him that would be activated and
that would serve to just be the one
force that drove him to do everything
that he did he would basically just
carry out the whims and wants of the
extremists of the order of st. Dumas and
that would be it now the other half of
this is that we end up finding out that
there is basically this being running
around called Ascalon and Ascalon is
essentially or at least as he's depicted
everything this jean-paul Valley was
supposed to be and again we'll get a
little more into that origin story as we
as we continue through this but
switching back to Bruce Wayne what
basically happens here is that with the
whole you know concept of him going to
see some body of course Ascalon shows up
to basically find a guy named brother
Coto now of course brother Coto is the
last of these members of the order of
st. Dumas that was not deemed to be
extreme enough all of his other members
are basically dead they've all been
killed off the idea is that Ascalon was
the one that did it
and so with Ascalon showing up here on
the scene the goal is to take out
brother Coto now of course this
coincides with the arrival of the person
that Bruce Wayne was trying to meet
which is cetana
now cetana is such a cool character when
it comes to DC Comics and she's one of
my absolute favorites in truth
she's largely tied to like John
Constantine to the demons angels sorcery
witchcraft magic kind of element of DC
which you usually find in vertigo but I
would say probably the coolest thing
about cetana
is that when she cast spells she speaks
backwards and that's what's so cool
about that is because literally like
whatever you go through her stories or
you read a comic that has her story in
it or has her and then it's as much a
game to decipher what it is as she's
saying as it is to learn about the plot
of the story and what it is that's
unfolding and you guys will see what I'm
talking about as we begin to go through
this but what this story also does is it
really goes back to the early days of
Bruce Wayne and it focuses largely on
the idea that him and Zatanna
had not necessarily been a romantic
couple so much as they had feelings for
one another that they never really acted
on but the idea was that cetana
basically served as this vector by which
Bruce Wayne could learn about the
various things that exist out there in
the world that he wasn't aware of before
because remember if you're new to DC and
you're going around and you're reading
DC Comics in a lot of ways you're like
Bruce Wayne or at least we're Swain when
he was younger they're superheroes
there's Superman there's Wonder Woman
there's the Green Lantern there's Batman
there's all these things that are new to
you but you only see DC through the lens
of superheroes it's not until you crack
open a vertigo book that you learn about
God and the devil and you learn about
the angels that stand between the two of
them the darker stories of Green Arrow
you start learning about all these
really dark elements of characters
you're basically waking up to a new
world
and that's exactly what cetana was doing
with Bruce Wayne when he was younger now
again going back to the moment here back
to the present day of course speaking
backwards she's basically able to
increase the gravity on Ascalon and
that's really about it they kind of you
know make their escape bail out while
they can along with the rest of the
members of the Baths family and so what
is up happening here is that we switch
back over of course again to the to the
belfry and so on but one of the sad
things about this and this is one of the
most notable things is that they bring a
doctor in for the purpose of basically
analyzing Nomos and trying to figure out
you know what's going on within from his
injuries and so on but the questions
also asked of Clayface is your interest
in me because of the fact that you're
trying to find a way to revert yourself
back to normal now again when it comes
to when it comes to Clayface he's
basically a good guy now but we as
readers know that because he was always
a bad guy with regards to the bad family
the time will come when he will
eventually turn back to being a villain
but the idea is that again the whole
question has to be asked what is this
Ascalon character how does it tie in to
jean-paul Valley and Azrael what in the
world is going on here now again this is
kind of the cool thing because what this
does is it basically focuses on the
nature of jean-paul himself coming to
terms with the fact that his past is
coming back to haunt him this is when we
get into the origin aspect a really kind
of the expanded origin aspect of
jean-paul so the way his character
worked because of the fact that he was
initially introduced as a guy who could
potentially be a Batman villain because
nightfalls served the purpose of
basically trying to find a way to remove
Bruce Wayne as Batman
and replace him with somebody else in
the same way that the the Clone Saga for
spider-man sought
remove Peter Parker and replace him with
Ben Riley the goal was to basically
bring in someone new
and so Azrael John Paul Valley was
introduced as a guy who was effectively
a religious zealot now the goal was
because of the fact that he had been
conditioned to be a religious zealot
eventually working alongside Batman and
Alfred he eventually cast his zealotry
aside and basically became a good guy
now this led directly into Batman
nightfall so that when Bane broke the
back of Bruce Wayne Azrael took up the
mantle and became Batman in his place
now following the events of nightfall DC
never really knew what to do with him
there was really nothing to do with his
character he had served his role served
his purpose they bounced him around here
and there different riders tried to make
him intriguing but for the most part he
fell into the role of a background
character and the result is that where
again he had his Nisha fans when it came
to the general population people who
just went out bought comics for a little
while wanted to read about what was
happening as Anna mentally stopped
jean-paul Valley kind of became this
thing in the past now the other half of
this is that Batman Begins to basically
talk to his Etana about him or about a
means by which he can basically go
through and begin gaining answers to
questions that he doesn't know the
answers to now the look and a shock from
cetana
is that Bruce Wayne's beginning to
remember something he shouldn't remember
and the implication here is that she
wiped his mind to keep him from
remembering something the fact that
Bruce Wayne wants to learn about like
what happened to the fate of Tim Drake
is Tim Drake really alive or as Tim
Drake dead because in the mind of Batman
Tim Drake is dead but there are aspects
of him and there are questions that are
being asked is Tim Drake actually alive
and so ultimately what we end up
learning is that because of the fact
that jean-paul Valley was attacked by
you know Ascalon ultimately his
reconditioning or his programming is
reactivated and what this means is it
sends John Paul Valley all the way back
to where he was before when he
originally popped up on the landscape in
DC and that's extremely important to
remember because what this is going to
do is serve the purpose of basically
restoring Azrael to the to the DC
landscape as really a a mainstream
character more or less or at least that
seems to be the case and at the same
time rework him to make him more
interesting and so what this does is it
switches back to the Past again it jumps
back to the younger days of Batman and
Zatanna
what is up happening is Etana basically
begins the process of talking to him
about different things that exist out
there differ
forms of magic and this discussion
coincides with what's going on in the
present day and so instead of bouncing
back and forth here and there between
the past and the present and making
things confusing what we'll say is this
for the character of Bruce Wayne
whether it's him experiencing it right
now with regards to his discussions for
real with with Zatanna whether it's him
experiencing it in the past in his
discussions with cetana when they were
both teenagers the idea is that Bruce
Wayne has largely remain hidden from the
world that is full of all kinds of
magics and things and what this is
designed to do is basically illustrate
how ill-equipped Batman would be against
these things how advanced and how
extreme these things are when it comes
to the character of Zatanna
it's one part sleight of hand and one
part legitimate magic and sorcery and
that's what makes her so cool is because
when she's casting spells you know make
it daytime in the middle of the night
when she's casting spells we're gonna go
fly when she's casting spells and she
says turn rain into flowers it was
basically her invoking legitimate magic
invoking these elements of this world
that Bruce Wayne isn't necessarily a
part of and that's the point that she
basically makes here when she was
younger I guess you know in this in this
circumstance she basically shows him
this orb his orbit will give him all the
answers to the questions that he wants
to have now what we find out is it in
the past she had also showed him they
warped she had also showed him this
Genesis or I'm not sure exactly how you
pronounce it but she shows him this fear
that if he holds it will give him the
answers to every question that he ever
has the problem with this is that the
questions are unending the first person
to have ever picked it up and held it
with their hand had this unending stream
of questions and they just held the or
of getting all these answers until they
died of starvation and hunger because
all they wanted were answers to
questions they were just totally
obsessed for Batman he's much in the
same boat
and that's exactly what is the Tana says
it's not like you're picking up the orb
and you're saying what are the winning
lotteries two more lottery numbers
tomorrow
Batman has all kinds of questions give
me answers about the Lazarus pits the in
metal Kim Drake give me answers about
all these things and that's what's it's
Hana says her problem you know what she
basically says is look this is not the
first time that you've come to me
seeking this orb trying to get answers
to the enth metal it's the fifth time
and I've wiped your mind every single
time it's happened basically this whole
high end this whole idea of Batman
searching out in metal the answer is
right there that's the whole basis with
Dark Knight's metal Dark Knight's metal
is this question what is in metal what's
this metal that exists out there that
has basically been ingested by various
superheroes through drinking water and
all kinds of things that have allowed
them to become superheroes in the first
place these are all the things that
Bruce Wayne wants to know the answers to
he's gotten these answers five times and
each time he's gotten these answers he
hasn't been able to handle it he
basically began to go insane and Zatanna
wiped his mind so that he wouldn't have
to worry about that anymore that's why
this is so crazy
because what this tells us is the forces
that we're gonna be dealing with in Dark
Knights metal are going to be extreme
it's going to be absolutely crazy
because the question is where does it
end up leading to and so again whether
what it does from here is it begins to
just kind of switch back over to the
main story itself which is to say the
whole idea of jean-paul Valley basically
being forced back into the system or at
least being forced back into his
programming and then taking on the
entirety of the bad family now the other
reason why this matters and the other
reasons why this is so significant is
because of the fact that jean-paul
Valley as Azrael is being depicted to us
here as someone not to be trifled with
and this really hits all the way back to
his original origin when he first popped
up on the scene because of the various
enhancement that he had because of the
fighting expertise that he had because
of what he was capable of he was in
every sense of the word a one-man army
and in this instance here it would be
nothing for him to take out the entirety
of the Baths family it would be the
easiest thing in the world to do the
other half of this is that this Ascalon
robot is basically trying to figure out
or trying to get answers to questions
and so what is basically done has gone
through and it's hijacked all these you
know Batman robots that belong to Lucas
Fox the son of Lucius Fox and is
basically using them to survey the
entire city now remember these members
of the order of st. Dumas are driven by
a religious zealot tree they look at
murder they look at crime they look at
you know these archaic 1950s you know
even 1800 ideologies they look at them
as being sinful as opposed to stepping
in the modern day and saying that's just
the way the world is now they look at
this is saying these people are living
in sin quite literally and the gold this
robot is to basically eliminate every
single last one of these now in terms of
jean-paul Valley try as they might they
cannot pull it off he's just that
capable and that's the important thing
about this with his character it's
designed to show us how dangerous he is
what he's operating at the absolute
match and the reason for that is because
if people are new to DC rebirth and
they're reading through Detective Comics
and they've seen these small appearances
of jean-paul Valley for the most part he
seems like an obscure character who's
totally irrelevant and can't do anything
he can do quite a few things he can
really take on the entirety of the bat
family by himself now given enough time
he would be completely overwhelmed and
that's what happens here you know he's
basically defeated by Cassandra and
that's really the end of that he's just
kind of taken down by one of the members
of the bat family knocked unconscious
and that's really the end of him for the
for the moment but the goal is to figure
out what to do next the goal is to
figure out what to do with jean-paul
Valley and this is where the wholesale
rework of his character comes into play
and that's a cool thing about this is is
this hits home at the very nature of DC
rebirth DC rebirth is not a reboot it
was never designed to be a reboot the
idea with DC rebirth is to say okay so
you guys didn't like everything that we
did alright there are classic roles that
characters played characters like the
classic Wally West that you want to see
come back we're gonna take those
characters that you guys loved from the
new 52 the way that we rebooted the way
they're reimagined we're gonna leave
them that way the characters that you
don't like we're gonna take them back to
their classic roots and that's exactly
what happens with jean-paul Valley but
the way this works is to take the
character that we know to reinvigorate
him but keep its classic roots intact
and so what it does is it basically sees
the creation of a new Batman suit and
this Batman suit functions according to
an artificial intelligence that was
basically designed for the purpose of
operating outside of the control of the
order of st. Dumas which is to say it
can basically replace the programming
that's already in jean-paul Valley when
the jean-paul Valley is thrown inside
this suit and then this inner battle
basically begins to take place where the
artificial intelligence of the suit
basically merges with jean-paul Valley's
mind and so it's this new artificial
intelligence versus the evil artificial
intelligence and the result is that it
leads to basically jean-paul Valley
emerging and becoming what looks like a
very similar iteration of his character
when he existed as Batman because of
that jean-paul Valley able to overcome
this system is programming in his body
and basically turn himself full on over
to this new AI as it's been provided to
basically reworks his character what it
does is it says okay this character of
Ezreal his original origin from Ezreal
annual number one from the sword of
Ezreal that's all still intact that's
all still the same this is just the next
step in this character's evolution and
that's the cool thing here is because
now he's being reworked he's being reef
unction now of course with the character
of Zatanna and with this Ashkelon robot
of course the question comes into into
play if it has nothing but questions and
if all it wants to do is learn is the
time just kind of pops up and says here
take this orb and get answers to the
questions that you're looking for now
the goal is to basically drive this
robot to the point that it becomes
insane but what is up happening is the
robot itself basically manifests in two
different ways the artificial
intelligence of the robot manifests as a
physical child and then the robot itself
just kind of functions out there as its
own artificial intelligence but the idea
is that the the biggest flaw this robot
had in terms of trying to function
trying to basically implement its goal
of purging sin from the city of Gotham
is that it was looking at the world
through the eyes of a child it was
saying here's how I would like the world
to be because I would like the world to
be this way the world is that way that's
not the way it is there's how this child
wanted the world to be then there's how
the way you know the way the world is
and the child was completely unable to
reconcile those two things and that was
the biggest problem with this robot but
the biggest information piece of this
robot drops is directly to Bruce Wayne
and what is simply tells Bruce Wayne is
that Tim Drake is alive and that's huge
because remember as far as Bruce Wayne
knows Kendrick is dead that happened all
the way back in the very first volume of
Detective Comics he ended up having the
father of that woman show up in Gotham
City for the purpose of taking all the
technology of Batman using it for their
own ends in an effort to basically
defeat some enemy we didn't know at the
time but actually turned out to be the
League of Shadows and what ended up
happening here is that in this onslaught
Tim Drake made it possible for the bat
family to escape dying but seemingly
sacrificed himself in the process what
ended up happening is that in truth Tim
Drake was whisked away by mr. Oz this
mysterious individual who somehow tied
into the Watchmen or at least we believe
he's tied into the watchman all roads
lead to the watchman when it comes to DC
rebirth in some former fashion every
story ties into the
Watchmen in some way whether it's
through mr. oz or even references to dr.
Manhattan but what this does is it sets
the stage for the hunt for Tim Drake to
try to figure out how to get him back
which inevitably will probably bring him
face to face
with mr. Oz himself and whoever it is
mr. oz is captured which could be
anybody that we haven't seen yet fingers
crossed
Superboy prong but with that being said
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain to make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob port you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]